>> Good Evening, I'm Jane and
I'd
Like to Welcome You to tonight's
event
which concludes the first term
of our
22nd Poet Laureate Consultant in
Poetry, Tracy.
The Librarian of Congress has
appointed her to a second term.
She was eager to do so because
Tracy has already accomplished a
great deal in
her signature laureate project.
With this project, Tracy seeks
to bring more poetry to rural
communities, communities like
Fairfield, California, where she
grew up.
This spring, with pilot trips
to New
Mexico, South Carolina and
Kentucky,
Tracy developed the model for
how she plans to spend her
second term. And also on behalf
of the library, I'd
like to thank senator of New
Mexico, Congressman James of
South Carolina,
Congressman Brett of Kentucky
and their
staff, of course, and the
Kentucky State Senator. I'd like
to thank all of them for
making Tracy's spring trip so
incredibly successful.
Tonight, in a talk entitled
Staying Human, Poetry in the Age
of Technology, Tracy will tell
you more about her project.
She'll also make the case for
poetry as
a reprieve from the noise of the
21st century life, and she'll
read a selection of her work,
including some
poems from her new anthology,
American
Journal: 50 Poems for Our Time,
being published with the
library.
After that, Ron Charles, editor
of the Washington Post Book
World and host of our Life of a
Poet series will talk with
Tracy about her poetry and her
plans in
the next year as Poet Laureate.
I'm very happy that all of you
could be with us for this
special evening.
So please join me in welcoming
our
United States Poet Laureate,
Tracy K. Smith. Thank you.
(Applause)
>> TRACY SMITH: Thank you.
Good evening.
It's such a delight and an honor
to be
back here in this wonderful,
wonderful building.
I wanted to talk about why
poetry feels
so important to me now
and a little bit about what
taking this
sense of mission into other
parts of the U.S. has felt like.
And I look forward to continuing
that conversation with Ron
Charles in the second half of
the program.
Poetry is not the language we
live in.
It's not the language of our
day-to-day errand-running and
obligation-fulfilling, not the
language with which we are asked
to justify ourselves to the
outside world.
It certainly isn't the language
to which commercial value has
been assigned.
But poetry, which awakens our
senses, frees us from the
tyranny of literal
meaning, and assures us of the
credible
reality of emotional truth puts
us in touch with something
bigger than
language, something I believe
each of us was perhaps fluent in
before the moment
when language became our chief
vehicle for meaning.
Before I go any farther, let me
say
that this lecture, like the
poetry I write, is the product
of a particular
imagination, one as informed by
belief
and a vast and mysterious, and
yet
orderly and purposeful universe,
as by a
deep curiosity about the voices
and lives of strangers.
Furthermore, I'm operating on
the
notion that poetry can save me
from disappearing into the
narrow version of myself I may
be tempted to resort to
when I feel lazy, or defeated,
or when my greedy ego takes
over.
I'm operating on the belief
that
poetry can restore me to the
large, original self I haven't
yet fully learned to recognize.
Poets have different names for
that self.
Stanley called it a "pool of
energy that has nothing to do
with personal
identity, but that falls away
from self, blends into the
natural universe.
"  Emerson believed it lived in
the same place the inner voice
does, and that it
had access to the large whole of
which
each of us are but small parts,
what he
called the oversoul, "the
silent, the universal beauty."
Elizabeth Bishop's view of
such
oneness, at least in her famous
poem In the Waiting Room, is
less consoling.
Suddenly, from inside came an
owe of
pain, a voice, not very loud or
long.
I wasn't at all surprised. Even
then I knew she was a foolish,
timid woman. I might have been
embarrassed, but wasn't. What
took me completely by surprise
was
that it was me, my voice and my
mouth. Without thinking at all,
I was my foolish aunt.
I, we, were falling, falling.
One of poetry's great effects
through its emphasis on feeling,
association,
music, and image, things we
recognize
and respond to even before we
understand why, is to guide us
toward the part of
ourselves so deeply buried that
it borders upon the collective.
Now, I feel strongly about
poetry for what it offers in
these terms, but I
also, more and more, recognize
its value as a remedy to the
various things that
have bombarded our lines of
sight and our thoughts, and that
tamper with our
ability or even our desire to
listen to that deeply rooted
part of ourselves.
I'm talking about the many
products,
services, networks, trends,
apps, tools,
toys, as well as the drugs and
devices for remedying their
effects that are
pitched at us nonstop.
in our browser sidebars, in the
pages
of present media, embedded in
movies and TV shows, on
airplanes, and taxis, and
trains, and even toilet stalls.
I guess more and more I see the
technology we live, listening
for and hearing into, as the
primary and most
effective vehicle of that sales
pitch.
, so much so that I now wonder
what came first -- the device,
or whatever the device is urging
us to click on and pay for.
The glib, facile, simplistic and
prefabricated language by which
we as consumers are constantly
surrounded it a
language that flatters us, that
urges us to indulge ourselves,
to get away from
it all, to be unique by opting
in, talking back, liking us on
Facebook,
leaving a review, sharing,
re-tweeting, etc.
It's a sell so smooth that its
terms have infiltrated the
language of other facets of
daily life -- that of education.
Rate your  Professor, does she
make the material relatable and
easily digestible, or did you
have to work to learn something.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: What are the
job outcomes and earning
potentials of your intended
major? Individual self-hood has
taken on a different tenor. We
brand ourselves.
What an awful verb, aligned as
it is with the practice of
burning the owner's  initials
into flesh.
We vie for followers on social
media.
We turn our experience into
content
that can be assimilated and
liked,
quickly and reassuringly by
others in our network.
Friendship is different now,
too.
We have allowed conversation to
be splintered and atomized by
the devices we invite to
interrupt and distract us.
We aren't listening to what or
whom we think we are.
I go so far as to say that much
of the time, perhaps as an
unconscious coping mechanism, we
aren't listening at all, not to
other  people, and least of all
to ourselves.
We can't afford to.
What does this have to do with
poetry?
As a writer, I'm convinced one
of the
only defenses against the
delegation of our market-driven
culture is to cling to
language that fosters humility,
awareness of complexity,
commitment to
the lives of others, and a
resistance to the easy and
false.
Poetry is one vehicle for this
humanizing version of language,
because the features of the poem
insist upon a
different value system. Rather
than numbing or drowning out the
difficult to describe, but
urgently sensed feelings that
are part of being human, poetry
invites us to tease them out, to
draw them into language that is
rooted in intricate thought and
strange impulse. Rather than
putting up a buffer between
ourselves and those outside our
immediate sphere, poems devise
means to contemplate those
others and to take in their
perspective.
Rather than solving,
side-stepping,
or denying problems, poems bear
witness to dark facets of
experience. They give us
vocabulary for the terror, the
shame, the regret, as well as
the
terms of hope resulting from the
choices
we make and those we consent to.
In other words, poems say hey,
come here, let me tell you what
it was like.
And they ask us to submit to
another experience of reality.
They disorient us from our home
base and they teach us to admit
and submit to
the feeling of  vulnerability,
to act upon empathy and
curiosity, and to
follow along, allowing sense to
accrue
at its own pace and upon its own
terms.
If you do that enough times with
a poem, you might begin to think
differently about actual
strangers.
You might also begin to
recognize that there are new
possibilities of feeling and
awareness available to you, ones
that take you far beyond those
pitched
to you by the marketing teams,
the corporations whose products
are at the
moment enjoying a good run.
In case I haven't said it
clearly, the language
circulating upon the surface of
the 21st century is in the
business of
pulling us away from the
interior, the
reflective, the singular, the
impractical, and the
un-summarizable.
In such occurrence, the language
of poetry is a radically
re-humanizing
force because it is one of the
only generally accessible
languages that
rewards us for naming things in
their realness and their
complexity. And despite what
social media would have us
believe, it is not the language
of sharing, and following, or
buying and
wearing, but rather that of
bearing deep
and un-abashed witness to the
urgencies
and upheavals of lived
experience that
comes closest to bringing us
into
visceral proximity with the
lives and plights of others.
That's not just distraction, and
it's not a luxury.
It's a means of
self-preservation, a
way of affirming commitment to
the belief that our lives can
and should
matter to one another and to
ourselves.
So this might be a good time for
a poem.
Can we listen to Laura read her
poem Heart Mine?
>> Heart, mine.
A bear batting at a beehive.
How clumsy the mind was with the
heart, wanting what it wanted.
The accountant, how timidly the
heart approached the business of
the mind,  counting what it
counted.
Light inside a cage, the way the
heart, bird trapped in an
airport, the way the mind. How
it flashed on the floor of the
phone booth, my last dime, and
this letter I didn't send. How
surprising to find it now, all
this love I must have felt.
>> TRACY SMITH: I love how
that sounds like a landline
phone call from long distance.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: Sometimes maybe
that's what poems are like.
They return us even just to the
recent past that feels so remote
and real.
I think any successful poem
teaches you how to read it.
In this case, hear it.
And Laura's poem Heard Mind
provides a good road map to that
process, beginning with the
title. You don't have it in
front of you, but it's
Heart/Mind. So the first thing a
reader might ask
is, what is that slash meant to
signal?
Is the poem called Heart/Mind,
is it
heart-mind, or as a participant
in a conversation that I had
recently at a
men's addiction rehabilitation
center in Kentucky pointed out,
perhaps it is
heart over mind, an emotional
reversal of the common notion of
mind over matter.
So the poem invites you to
question and theorize. And then
it begins to tell you what it
thinks of itself.
In this poem, I'm going to
repeat the early stanzas, with
metaphors that unfold into
concrete and surprising visceral
examples over the span of a few
lines. They set up a pattern
that becomes useful to the
reader once the poem
becomes more spare and
gesturel.
A bear batting at a beehive, how
clumsy the mind always was with
the heart, wanting what it
wanted.
The blizzard's accountant, how
timidly the heart approached the
business of the mind, counting
what it counted.
I love what happens when I get
these strange images that give
me an intense, you know, like,
feeling.
A bear batting at a beehive. Not
only do we have all those silly,
fun bees, but you have the image
of this
big animal, angrily and hungrily
swatting at is something. And
you have a sense of danger,
threat and counterthreat, on
both sides of the equation. So
the poem begins with this
strange
sense of fraught balance. And
then how clumsy, which
characterizes that bear.
So it's not such a threat.
It's just ham-fisted. How clumsy
the mind always was with the
heart. And suddenly the heart is
the hive. There's something in
there that is wanted and also
worth protecting. Wanting what
it wanted.
So those first four lines of the
poem guide you into a sense of
all of the potential registers
of emotion that are making this
metaphor happen. And the  second
-- or the third stanza does the
same thing. The blizzard's
accountant. I don't have a way
of picturing that.
I'm already kind of like on
alert from having had some
senses activated by the
if IRS first metaphor, but I've
got to let the next stanza show
me what to see.
How timidly.
Maybe that's the accountant, the
heart approaches the business of
the mind. Of course.
What kind of math would suffice
in the
face of a blizzard's worth of
snow? And yet,  counting what it
counted, the heart persists. By
the time in the poem that we
reach
the lines, light inside a cage,
the way
the heart -- which ends with a
dash --
bird, trapped in an airplane the
airport the way the mind, dash.
We can instinctively see the
little drama that is to be
played out in our imagination.
Those lines become a
shorthand for a process that we
are now educated and equipped to
complete on our own. Yet even
having taught us how to work
with what we've come to expect,
the poem still manages to
surprise us. I love this. I
think every poem, every fully
realized poem, finds a way to
surprise its reader. Moreover,
as a poet, I understand that a
poem is only finished, only
fully
realized if it succeeds in
alerting me to something I
couldn't have been capable of
seeing at the outset,
something I couldn't have known
to say were it not for all of
the things that the process of
writing the poem has led me to
say.
Her poem moves through images
of the heart as an indomitable
beacon, something uncagable. And
then the image of the mind,
trapped, bumping up against
invisible barriers, forever
barred from where it seeks to
go. And then she leaps from
there to the sense of
frustration and desperation in
that image of the last dime on
the mucky, disgusting phone
booth floor. Speaking of
technology.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: Let me
concede that there are some
things that have
definitely been improved upon.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: All of the
visceral feelings that the poem
draws upon from its very opening
work to invest its
arrival with a palpably felt
urgency. I don't believe it was
a plan, something outlined and
plotted from the
start, but rather that moving
through the register of those
different, distinct feelings
created the momentum that pulled
her to the poem's closure,
which
incidentally, resists metaphor.
Perhaps the poem is free from
the need for corollary, invested
as it is in the confluence of
newly activated feelings.
These are the final lines of
the poem.
This letter I didn't send, how
surprising to find it now.
All this love I must have felt.
And how did this poem speak to
my concerns about  market-driven
language? I think about it this
way.
We don't read poems only for
their rhetorical stance they
take, or for the arguments they
may actively or subtly make
about their conscious material.
We also -- and I'd argue, mostly
-- read them for how they direct
our attention in ways that are
antithetical to mere utility.
In Heart/Mind, Laura is not
making editorial-like claims
against the language of the
marketplace or of commodity.
But in urging us to think and
respond
as it does, the poem
persuasively unsettles the
unthinking or automatic ways we
often experience content,
language, and narrative.
It is in this manner that this
and other poems invite our
dissatisfaction with the view of
the world as a place
made up mostly of resources to
exhaust or consume.
Let's listen to another poem.
This is called Music from
Childhood by John Yao.
>> Music from childhood.
You grew up hearing two
languages. Neither fits your
fits.
Your mother informs you moon
means window to another world.
You begin to hear words born of
sounds buried inside their
mouths. A row of yellow windows
and a painting of them.
Your mother informs you moon
means window to another world.
You decide it is better to step
back and sit in the shadows.
A row of yellow windows and a
pint painting of them. Someone
says you can see a blue pa goda,
or a red rocket ship. You decide
it is better to step back and
sit in the shadows.
Is it because you saw a black
asteroid fly past your window?
Someone said you could see a
blue pagoda or a red rocket
ship.
I tried to follow in your
footsteps,
but they turned to water.
Is it because I saw a black
asteroid fly past my window? The
air hums.
A circus performer riding a
bicycle towards the ceiling. I
tried to follow in your
footsteps, but they turned to
water.
The town has started sinking
back into its commercial. The
air hums.
The circus performer riding a
bicycle towards the ceiling.
You grew up hearing two
languages. Neither fits your
fits.
The town has started sinking
back into its commercial.
You begin to hear words more in
the sounds buried inside their
mouths.
>> TRACY SMITH: So this poem
behaves quite differently.
Firstly, you probably noticed a
little
bit of repetition, not enough to
make you confident of a pattern
that you were going to be able
to anticipate.
So this poem is a pantoom, the
second and fourth lines of
the poem occur further down,
only once, and then the next
stanza, the lines that sit in
that place will occur further
down.
And so it creates this sense of
eerie
deja vu, almost like you're
being gaslighted, did I hear
that, do I know that? Some of
the other behavior in the poem,
you probably  noticed there are
statements that don't finish.
And there are shifting
pronouns. There's a you that's
being addressed
that seems like maybe the
speaker talking to himself. Then
later that you seems to become a
specific person. I tried to
follow in your footsteps, but
they turned to water. There are
visual images in the poem.
There's a sense of place.
But none of it feels anchored so
that I could confidently say
these are the terms of this
person's life. What I do feel
confident of is what seems to
accrue emotionally through the
poem, the sense of searching, of
turning
back, of recalling something
that's partially clear.
There's even an interesting way
that
some of -- you don't have the
line breaks in front of you, so
you have to trust me.
but one line leads into another
in a way that almost feels
linear and logical, and then
something shifts.
So in the second stanza of the
poem,
the beautiful line, you begin to
hear
words mourn the sounds buried
inside their mouths. I can't
tell you exactly what that
means.
But mourn, sounds, buried,
mouths, creates a kind of
authority for the line that I'm
going to goal upon a bit more.
And I think of loss, of
language and voices.
But then the next line -- so
buried inside their mouths, a
row of yellow. And maybe this is
just me, but after mouths and I
see a row of yellow, I think
maybe teeth or something is what
I'll see next, but no, a row of
yellow windows and a painting of
them.
So suddenly we go from this
almost
philosophical, mournful
perspective to a shifted gaze of
looking out, maybe looking out.
Maybe it's just a painting of
someone -- something that is
looked out upon. So it's a poem
that's not going to guide you by
the hand.
But if you surrender to did you
get it, you feel many things. I
think about maybe someone who
grew up in a household with more
than one language.
But I also feel the sense of
interiority and privacy that's
so active
in this poem that I feel that
any  person, anywhere is living
in two languages.
The language of the self, and
the language that comes from
outside.
I shared this poem at an air
Force base in New Mexico with
men and women
enlisted in the air force and
air base employees and military
spouses. It's the kind of poem
that requires you to let go of
that wish for linear narrative
and respond instead to the
tone, the accrual of images, to
the almost haunting effects of
hearing every line repeated once
and no more.
I asked what people noticed.
That's the question I asked the
students in my classroom, as
well as the audience members who
have attended readings I've
given in rural communities in
New Mexico, South Carolina, and
Kentucky over the last several
months.
And just as with Laura's poem,
which in a room of men working
to overcome addiction activated
very specific memories of
struggling with similar
questions of mind over -- or
reason
versus feeling or urge, John's
poem reminded airmen of their
time in the service, of seeking
perhaps to follow in the
footsteps of a parent or family
member, and then finding
themselves in their own lives
lost at times without a clear
model or guide.
The poem with its sense of
rootlessness, of struggle to
make sense of disparate
languages, also reminded people
of displacement, the kind one
feels in childhood or
adolescence, as well as the kind
one feels upon being
deployed, say, or being uprooted
again and again by assignment in
different places. One audience
member spoke about the
occasional feelings of social or
racial isolation he sometimes
feels in the service.
Just as none of the addicts
felt the
need to argue that  Laura's poem
is about addiction, nobody at
the men's
rehab center felt the need to
say John's is a poem -- I'm
sorry. Nobody at the air force
base felt the
need to say that Yao's is a poem
about being in the armed forces.
But in both cases, the poems
afforded listeners with new
images, new metaphors, and new
vocabularies for living with the
feelings indigenous to
their lives, whoever they were.
That's one of the remarkable
things poems do. One of the ways
poems lead us first
more deeply into ourselves, and
then more naturally toward the
areas of common feeling we share
with  others. That's how poems
teach us to recognize that there
are forms of community that
exist across or inside of the
obvious dividing lines we're
taught to respect.
My rural outreach  project, even
in
just three pilot trips, has
awakened a belief in the real
possibility that we might learn
to become open to
participation in realtime
communities forged along varied
and sometimes unlikely lines.
And it's urged a powerful
submission
to feelings of shared
vulnerability, humility, doubt,
and trust. It's been a privilege
to share my own work and the
work of other contemporary
poets with strangers that
crowdsourcing algorithms tell me
I ought to have nothing in
common with.
And to hear people say things
like, I'm white. You're black.
I'm from this place. You're from
another. And yet when you talk
about your
father, you re-stormy restore my
own father to me. This that
happens again and again though
the vocabulary is different from
person to person and poem to
poem.
I think my interest in such a
project
is an extension of my own belief
or wish that Americans of all
backgrounds might have something
quietly urgent and humanizing to
offer one another. But in order
to get to it, we have to turn
down the volume on all the many
sources seeking to sell us on
the notion
of an unmendable divide, because
that's what they're doing.
They're selling us on a product
which is strife. In order to get
to community, we have
to go quiet, slow down, allow
ourselves
to be both vulnerable and brave,
and approach one another with an
idea as
simple as I'm me, you're you,
we're not the same, and yet
perhaps we can feel safe here
together talking about something
as simple as a poem.
Poems encourage the notion
that your life must be as
important to you as mine is to
me. And they encourage the more
difficult notion that your life
must be as
important to me as my own life,
that I
can only truly honor and protect
myself by honoring and
protecting you. Now, maybe that
last bit is a distant dream.
The purview of a few great poets
and philosophers. But I hope it
isn't.
Either way, I believe that
poetry helps bridge the gap
between self-centeredness
and tribalism, and true
compassion.
Poems do this in myriad ways.
One of them is by helping to
inoculate
us against the catchy,
inescapable, strategically
biased language of the
market, firing away at us from
every direction in its ceaseless
ploy to be the only language.
Thank you.
(Applause)
>> TRACY SMITH: Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you. I want to welcome Ron
Charles up to the stage. I want
to welcome Ron Charles up to the
stage.
(Applause)
>> RON CHARLES: So beautiful
and inspiring. This is on.
>> TRACY SMITH: No secrets up
here now.
>> RON CHARLES: Thank you.
Let me get this for my Instagram
followers.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: A few years
ago in an essay, you asked with
a certain degree
of exasperation, why is there a
vast majority in this country
that suspects poetry has nothing
to do with the real world?
What is the source of that
suspicion?
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, I'm
biased.
I think it has to do with fear,
because
the question that often follows
that,
why is it so hard.
I think, you know, part of it
probably
has to do with the way that
we're taught
to -- I want to say summarize
things, prove that we've
comprehended, demonstrate our
knowledge and expertise.
Part of it has to do with the
way that tests produce a lot of
anxiety, and so we think this
poem is out to get me.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: Some of it
has to do
with the awful question that
many people ask, what do you
think this poem is trying to
say?
>> RON CHARLES: Yes. Do you know
what it would mean to  America's
high school students to see the
Poet Laureate of the United
States stand there and say, I
don't know
exactly what that means?
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: It's such a
rebuke of a thousand horrible
high school experiences.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah.
The position of the Poet
Laureate is undefined, isn't it?
>> TRACY SMITH: It is. Yeah.
It is a kind of freedom, you
know.
>> RON CHARLES: And terror.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: I mean, it's
a strange position. It's been
funded by the federal
government, but not officially
answerable to the federal
government. You don't have to
write a poem for Donald Trump's
birthday or any other occasional
things like that.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: He's not here,
is he?
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: What inspired
you to
go on the road with this
project?
>> TRACY SMITH: I had this wish
to
test out this idea that if we
can stop
trying to tell ourselves what
other
people think and just talk, we
can maybe find ourselves not
yelling, not, you know, enraged,
and maybe hearing
something that's useful and that
resonates somehow. I grew up
going to church. And I remember
feeling that. I remember
feeling, I love these people. I
see them. But I don't agree with
them on everything. And yet
somehow this is a community that
works.
And I think families are like
that, too. And so why can't the
nation be like that? So I had
this fantasy that poetry could
be one of these topics that
urges us to be quiet. And all
the adjectives that I talked
about.
And I wonder if it would be
possible to go out there and say
something meaningful to each
other through the vehicle of
this art form.
And then the opportunity
presented itself.
>> RON CHARLES: Why did you
focus on rural areas?
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, as a
writer I spend most of my time
going to cities or college
towns. And then I feel like
there's this tendency to divide
our sense of what America is
into two regions. I mean, it's
silly because it's such a big
place.
But we have the urban, coastal
region,
and then the require center the
rural center. I thought I spend
a lot of time in
places where people will
probably go.
So why not see what happens if I
can cross that line.
>> RON CHARLES: When you went to
these towns, who came?
Were they
beret-wearing hipsters?
>> TRACY SMITH: Some of the
towns were so small it was
people who were aware an event
was happening, and that's
something that doesn't usually
happen. So a pretty healthy
cross-section.
When we were in South Carolina,
the
locations that representative C
Clyburn curated for us, were
connected historically. They had
a strong sense of participation
in the Civil Rights Movement.
And I think that meant that many
of the people who came were
members of a black church that
we visited.
And they came. There were alumni
and community members
of a school, old summerton High
School,
one of the schools  desegregated
during the Brown V. Board of
Education. Members of that class
came. Many people came because
they said there's a black woman
doing something on this national
scale, I want my kids who are
black to see this.
It a A similar thing happened
but in opposite terms when I was
in another community. It'll come
to me sometime tonight.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: That's the
problem with doing things so
quickly. Where it was a white
family who said we live in a
town that's really racially
divided and I want my kids to be
able to cross that line, so I
want them to come here.
>> RON CHARLES: Just coming
was crossing a barrier. Did you
get responses that surprised
you, that you hadn't expected?
>> TRACY SMITH: I don't know
what I was expecting.
I was a little bit just curious.
So anything felt useful.
There were people who wrote
poetry,, who said I'll read a
poem.
We have some great recordings of
people saying here's a chance to
read a poem. Someone at the air
force base said I write poems in
this secret journal that I don't
want anybody to see, but I'll
read you a couple now.
>> RON CHARLES: Wow.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: You read a
variety of poems, not just your
own, other people's. What kinds
of poems went over well?
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, the two
that I shared tonight are two
that I've read before.
And I felt like people listen
and have theories about the
poem, or want to talk about what
the poems remind them of.
There are two others that
perhaps we'll hear tonight.
>> RON CHARLES: We will.
>> TRACY SMITH: That behave
in different ways.
One goes back to childhood and
narrates a somewhat familiar
experience and then aligns it
with a larger sense.
And another that's a family
story about addiction within a
family. Yeah.
People are -- they know I'm not
going to test them. If they know
-- and this is something I kind
of go out of my way to say is,
I'm just curious. This is what I
say to my students. What do you
notice? Anything that you notice
is useful and valuable to talk
about? Maybe it will activate
somebody else's feeling of
something that they noticed.
So just, let's hear it. Maybe
it's because it's a community
where people know each other,
but there hadn't been a sense --
in some ways, most of the poems
have gone over because people
have wanted to talk about them.
>> RON CHARLES: Now, you have
a new collection coming out,
Wave in the Water, next Tuesday?
>> TRACY SMITH: It's out.
>> RON CHARLES: It's a
beautiful collection.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: I wonder if you
would read the title poem.
>> TRACY SMITH: Sure.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: So this poem
narrates an encounter.
I hope it's somewhat clear, but
I
attended something, and that's
where the scene that occupies
most of the poem took place.
Wave in the water, for the ring
shouters.
One of the women greeted me. I
love you, she said.
She didn't know me, but I
believed her.
And a terrible new ache rolled
over in
my chest, like in a room where
the drapes have been swept back.
I love you, I love you, as she
continued down the hall, past
other
strangers, each feeling pierced
suddenly by pillars of heavy
light.
I love you, throughout the
performance, in every hand-clap,
every
stomp, I love you in the rusted
iron
chains someone was made to drag
until
love let them be unclasped and
left empty in the center of the
ring.
I love you in the water where
they
pretended to wade, singing that
old blood-deep song that dragged
us to those banks and cast us
in. I love you.
The angles of it scraping at
each
throat, shouldering past the
swirling dust motes in those
beams of light that
whatever we now knew we could
let
ourselves feel knew to clip.
Oh, woods. Oh, dogs.
Oh, trees. Oh, gun. Oh, girl
run.
Oh, miraculous, many gone.
Oh, lord Lord, oh Lord,
oh, Lord, this love the trouble
you promiseed.
>> RON CHARLES: What does it
mean to
say I love you to a stranger in
this poem?
>> TRACY SMITH: That's the
question
that set that poem into motion.
It felt like such a gift and it
hurt at
the same time and it allowed so
much to
come out, so many conflicting
feelings.
>> RON CHARLES: Not because
you doubted her sincerity.
>> TRACY SMITH: I could have
because
she said it to everyone, but it
was a
genuine thing, vulnerable
gesture. I wanted to go back to
that and figure out where that
came from and what it had given
me. I don't know what it means,
but I have a feeling that we
kind of need to learn what it
means.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes, indeed.
What does it mean to be Poet
Laureate in these contentious
times, when everything from
what's decent to what's
science is a matter of such hot
debate?
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, I feel
like
it's added urgency to my belief
that we are better when we're
more attentive,
when we can sort of say I'm not
going to
accept this, like, word package
without parsing it and testing
its validity in whatever terms
that are valid, like
emotional or otherwise.
And I've got to move -- I'll be
better-equipped to just be in
this world if I'm moving away
from what I'm certain
of and say there has got to be
something
I can stand to learn, got to be
something I don't recognize
about myself
that could somehow, if I can
face it,  help.
>> RON CHARLES: Your example is
quite
different than the role that
many writers are playing in this
era, which is to be very
political. You're being
political in a very different
way that I think is really
provocative. Last year you said
in an interview, poetry helps me
contend with the small
of the spirit, the greed, the
dishonesty, the disregard for
the lives of others at the root
of American politics.
Fortunately we've moved beyond
all that.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: In your
introduction to American
journal, which is an anthology
you'll be bringing out this
fall, you say that you hope
those poems
might make us a little less
alien to each other. Such a
great goal.
How can a poem do that?
>> TRACY SMITH: It does it in
a lot of small ways that add up
to something. One, it says I'm
sitting here in this chair where
I'm comfortable, and I'm reading
about something that makes me
have to, sort of, start from
scratch and try and understand,
because I want to. I want to do
that work. Oh, this is something
that's connected
to a voice, a theoretical
person. Somehow I'm moving away
from my own
sense of being and into another
person's. I do believe that's
good practice.
>> RON CHARLES: Modeling the
way we should be as citizens
more.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah.
>> RON CHARLES: Would you
read a poem
called Refuge from your new book
on page 73?
>> TRACY SMITH: Sure.
>> RON CHARLES: Can they buy
these books?
>> TRACY SMITH: Product
placement.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: Refuge.
Until I can understand why you
fled,
why you are willing to bleed,
why you
deserve what I must be willing
to cede, let me imagine you are
my mother in
Montgomery, Alabama, walking to
Kansas rather than riding the
bus. I know what they call you.
I know what they try to convince
you you  lack.
I know your tired ankles, the
sudden thunder of your laugh,
until I want to
give you what I myself deserve,
let me
love you by loving her.
Your sister in a camp in Turkey,
16, deserving of everything.
Let her be my daughter, who has
curled her neat hands into
fists, insisting nothing is fair
and I have never loved her.
Naomi, lips set in a scowl,
young heart ransacking itself.
Let me lend her passion to your
sister,
and love her for her living
rage, her
need for more, and now, and all.
Let me leap from sleep if her
voice
sounds out afraid from down the
hall.
I've seen men like your father
walking
up Harrison Street now that the
days are getting longer.
Let me love them as I love my
own father, whom I phoned once
from a valley
in my life to say what I feared
I'd
never adequately said, voice
choked, stalled, hearing the
silence spread around us like
weather.
What would is cost me to say it
now
to a stranger's father, walking
home to
our separate lives together?
>> RON CHARLES: It reenacts
the golden rule, at the center
of every
ethical system, that we should
feel what someone else is
feeling. Until I understand you,
a pretty hopeful line, that we
will if we make the effort.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. Or
we'll be like those kids at the
table, like 12, with a couple
Brussels sprouts.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: But either
way there is time.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah. It's
just such a poem for this
moment.
We've got a recording of a poem
called Second Estrangement. Can
you set that up?
>> TRACY SMITH: It's a poem by a
poet who -- it comes from her
most recent
collection which is called Black
Mariah
thinking about the African
diaspora in different parts of
the world. Those are the large
thematic questions.
But more urgent or salient is
the sense
of displacement that maybe any
person can feel access to.
So this is a poem that kind of
builds
that in these really familiar
and very visceral terms.
>> Second estrangement.
Please raise your hand, whomever
else
of you has been a child, lost in
a
market or a mall, without
knowing it at
first, following a stranger
accidentally, thinking he is
yours, your family or parent,
even grabbing for his
hand, even calling the word you
said
then for "father," only to see
the face
look strangely down, utterly
foreign,
utterly not the one who loves
you, you
who are a bird, suddenly stunned
by the
glass partitions of rooms.
How far the world you knew and
tall,
and filled finally with
strangers.
>> RON CHARLES: I love that that
poem reenacts that sense of
alienation and fear in a way
that makes us feel like everyone
else.
It overcomes the very problem it
enacts.
It's incredibly clever.
>> TRACY SMITH: I love the
way it guides you. You don't
know that's where it's going.
The title might alert you to
something. It begins please
raise your hand. And I think
that's the first line. And I'm a
good student, I want to do it.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: And then whoever
else among you. And then we
descend step by step into this
feeling of, you know, first
you're just alone in a mall.
Then you're lost. And you're
without this person. And then we
realize there's a private
language, the word you used then
for father.
It could almost behave like
John's  poem. Maybe there's a
real language barrier, or maybe
just I'm not at home anymore.
And the image of the bird. Birds
come up in poems, I guess.
But it creates that feeling of
abrupt shock.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah.
>> TRACY SMITH: And so all of
the,
you know, willingness that we
have demonstrated to follow this
poem leads
us to that same place of being
lost, and scared, and stuck.
>> RON CHARLES: We've all felt
that. There is a connection.
As much anxiety as there's been
about the political contention
of our age, it's not the worst
it's been. We've got the Civil
War. Several of your poems are
inspired by the civil war, draw
text from the civil war, in
fascinating ways. Can you tell
us about that and read a
poem called Declaration?
>> TRACY SMITH: Sure.
The Civil War Kind of Got
-- I was invited by the National
Port
Rat Portrait Gallery in the year
leading up to the 150th
anniversary of the beginning of
the Civil War to contribute a
poem for an exhibition.
There were going to be portraits
and poems.
And I had to sort of say I want
to do
this because I want to write a
poem, but I don't know how to
make myself want to write about
the civil war, which I've never
liked learning about. I was
talking with another black
writer recently about how every
time we would get to that moment
in history growing up where it
was slavery and the Civil War,
we as the black kids in the
classroom were made to feel
shame, like how could this have
happened to us.
And so I was conditioned to feel
like ugh, here we go again.
But I wanted to do it so I said,
what would black soldiers have
experienced in this conflict?
And I found a couple of really
great books that contain all
these primary documents that
prevented me from doing what I
wanted to do, which was to write
something in my own voice, and
urged me simply to listen and
bring these voices into
conversation with each other.
>> RON CHARLES: What were
these documents?
>> TRACY SMITH: Letters that
soldiers and their families had
written to each
other and to Abraham Lincoln,
depositions that veterans and
their bid doze and descendants
had given after the
war, well into the 20th century
in an attempt to get the
pensions that they as veterans
should have been entitled to,
but that they were denied
because having
been born into slavery, they
didn't have birth certificates,
marriage licenses, nothing
attesting to the fact that they
had changed their name after
emancipation.
So that's where that came from.
And suddenly this history felt
so alive, and active, and
relevant.
>> RON CHARLES: Because you were
hearing voices that are usually
suppressed in history.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. Or
they're just absent.
Or they get reduced to, this
happened to these people.
And so then I said I want to get
deeper into this.
the Declaration of independence
seemed like another source to
say what would it say to now if
I could have my way with it. So
this is the poem that came from
that. And it's an erasure.
So there are what I think of as
the
specific terms that clarify that
this
is, you know, a complaint
against the King of England, and
suddenly it felt like it was
large enough to include other
voices.
Declaration.
He has sent hither swarms of
officers to harass our people.
He has thundered our -- ravaged
our -- destroyed the lives of
our -- taking
away our -- abolishing our most
valuable
and altering fundamentally the
forms of our.
In every stage of these
oppressions, we have petitioned
for redress in the most humble
terms.
Our repeated petitions have been
answered only by repeated
injury.
We have reminded them of the
circumstances of our immigration
and settlement here.
Taken captive on the high seas
to
bear.
>> RON CHARLES: You said very
briefly as you began it was an
erasure. Can you explain that a
little more?
>> TRACY SMITH: Sure.
If I look at the whole document,
and
delete most of it, and tried to
hear a
quieter voice under that
official voice -- and I didn't
set out to do that really, I
don't think.
I was reading it to see what --
I was trying to write a poem
about Thomas Jefferson. I was
reading it to see what I could
get from him. And then I heard
this other thing saying, forget
about him. Listen to this.
>> RON CHARLES: Would you
read a poem called I Will Tell
You the Truth About This, and
maybe explain the background of
that poem?
>> TRACY SMITH: Sure. So this is
the Civil War poem that I was
talking about.
And it's just a collection of
letters,
some almost in their entirety
written by these black soldiers
and their families. And then
there are a couple of sections
-- it's a long poem. I'll read
you the two sections? You want
me to read the first letter?
Okay.
>> RON CHARLES: Is this a single
letter or a composite?
>> TRACY SMITH: This is one
letter. All of these are actual
letters. And even the spelling.
I laughed because it seemed
urgent. I will tell you the
truth about this.
I will tell you all about it.
Carlisle, Pennsylvania, November
21st, 1864.  Mr. Abraham
Lincoln, I want to know, sir,
if you please, whether I can
have my son released from the
Army. He is all the support I
have now.
His father is dead, and his
brother, that was all the help I
had, he has been wounded twice.
He has not had anything to send
me yet.
Now I am old and my head is
blossoming for the grays.
And if you do, I hope the Lord
will bless you and me. They say
that you will sympathize with
the poor.
He belonged to the 8th regiment
colored troop. He is a sergeant.
Mark Welcome is his name.
>> RON CHARLES: Did you know
that these letters existed?
>> TRACY SMITH: No.
I'll tell you the book that they
are collected in. I'm sure they
are probably here in this great
building.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: But this is
how I found them.
Families and freedom, a
documentary history of African
American kinship in
the Civil War era, edited by Ira
and Leslie.
And that was published in 1997.
And then the depositions are
collected in Voices of
Emancipation, Understanding
Slavery, the Civil War, and
Reconstruction Through the U.S.
Pension Bureau Files.
Edited by Elizabeth and Donald.
>> RON CHARLES: That's
incredibly poignant.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. This is
what we should've been reading
in those classes where I felt so
called out, you know.
Because they do what so little
does, which is to restore the
sense of sanity and actually,
like, blood, and life, and
voices, and stories to history,
you know. So often it's not the
first version of history that
you get as a student.
>> RON CHARLES: You were in
South Carolina and Kentucky,
places where
debate about how to memorialize
the Civil War are still running
hot. Did that subject come up?
>> TRACY SMITH: This poem
came up.
(Chuckling) And it was something
people heard in a way that's
similar to how I heard those
voices. It was something that
people would come up to me
afterwards. When I'm reading my
own poems I don't always say
what do you notice. That seems
wrong.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: So if somebody
notices something, maybe they'll
say it afterward. And this is
the poem that people want to
talk about, because it does that
for them, too, in some way.
When we were in South Carolina,
we were
in a place where I think the
55th Massachusetts volunteers
had fought. And that was
commemorated. And so there was,
you know, a sense of this is our
history.
This is here, in a way.
>> RON CHARLES: Right. Yeah.
You're going to read a poem
called the political poem.
>> TRACY SMITH: Okay.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: What is the
function
of a political poem in an age
like ours? It seems different
than during the
Vietnam War, the Civil Rights
Era, what is a political poem
nowadays and how does this poem
you're about to read answer that
question?
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, I think
a
political poem in any age is
valuable if it can challenge the
easy sense of us versus them. So
political poems that fail don't
do that. They say I'm on the us,
which is good,
and I'm going to call out these
them.
>> RON CHARLES: Just propaganda,
rallying cry.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. Even if
you're thinking in terms of
justice you're making bad art if
that's the way you're going to
do it.
A good political poem says
perhaps this is what I as a
person believe, but I've got a
question and I'm going to have
to explore it in ways that are
going to put that on the line
and call it into question and
move me toward an
uncomfortable sense of, perhaps
complicity or implication in
part of the problem as I see it.
I want to do an organic kind of
walk
through and think about what I'm
made to acknowledge.
I feel like there are lots of
poems that do that.
I like  adding the title,
Political Poem to this poem,
because that makes you feel
like, God, what is going to come
at me?
And this is a poem that wasn't
even
written with politics in mind.
>> RON CHARLES: It definitely
plays with that theme and its
title in a very witty, conscious
way.
>> TRACY SMITH: No, this is a
poem
that I wrote thinking about -- I
was in Vermont. I actually was
having a dream that I was in a
room where there was a poem as a
mural on a wall that I was
reading aloud to somebody. And
then I said this is not a poem
by somebody else.
If I wake up, this can be my
poem.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: So I got up
and sat. I was in Vermont.
So I think Robert Frost, you
know, mowers were probably in
the air.
And I recaptureed to the extent
that poem. And I published it.
And it was called the mowers.
And later I read it and I said,
I think this is going to make
more sense if I change the
title.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah. Or make
difference sense.
>> TRACY SMITH: Better sense.
>> RON CHARLES: 54.
>> TRACY SMITH: Political poem.
If those mowers were each to
stop at
the whim, say, of a greedy
thought, and then the one off to
the left were to let his arm
float up, stirring the air with
that wide, slow, underwater
gesture
meaning hello, and you there,
aimed at
the one measure more than a mile
away to the right, and if he in
his work were to
pause, cash catching that call
and send
back his own slow dance meaning
yes, and
here, threaded to a single long
nerve
before remembering his tool and
shearing another message into
the Earth, letting
who can say how long graze past
until another thought or just
the need to know
might make him stop and look up
again at
the other, raising his arm as if
to say something like, still,
and, oh.
And then to catch the flicker of
joy
rise up along those other legs
and flare into another bright
yes that sways a moment in the
darkening air. Their work would
carry them into the
better part of the evening, each
mowing
ahead and doubling back, then
looking up
to catch sight of his echo,
sought and
held in that instant of common
understanding.
The speed of it coming out only
after
both have turned back to face
the sea of
yet, and blow.
If they could, and if what
glimmered like a fish were to
dart back and forth
across that wide, wordless
distance, the day, though gone,
would never know the ache of
being done.
If they thought to, or would, or
even
half wanted, their work, the
humming,
human engine pushed across the
grass, and the grass blade after
blade assenting, would take
forever.
But I love how long it would
last.
>> RON CHARLES: How can such
a poem
help us rethink the political
stand off we find ourselves in?
>> TRACY SMITH: Well, it's kind
of
begging one to change the scale
upon which we're thinking and
say, okay, it's
easy to get mad at, like, a big
group of -- a demographic.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes.
>> TRACY SMITH: But if you
reduce it to one person out
there doing his version of what
you're over here doing, maybe it
will feel different.
>> RON CHARLES: Yes. Lovely.
Really lovely. There's a whole
bunch of people nearby
you need to talk to.
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: In the
introduction
to Wave in the Water, you write
this is why I love poems. They
invite me to sit down and listen
to a voice speaking softly and
passionately about what it feels
like to be alive. Usually the
someone doing the talking, the
poem's speaker, is a person I've
never person I wouldn't get the
chance to meet were it not for
this poem. More and more the way
we get our news, interact online
through Facebook and other
social media, we only interact
with people who think just like
we do.
We don't see people that don't
think like us. We silence them,
avoid them, listen to the right
news, etc.
Can we listen to a poem called
My Brother at 3:00 A.M., and can
you tell us about that?
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. This is
by Natalie Diaz. It's from a
collection called When My
Brother Was -- there's a family
in the center of the book. It's
on such a scale that I don't
know
if it's a real, live family or
an imagined family that allows a
certain dramatic situation to
play out. But there's a brother
in that family
who is an addict and is, you
know, causing all of this
upheaval, changing
the way that the speaker of the
poem
thinks about herself, about what
she belongs to, what the threats
are.
But it's also a book that is
kind of like testifying to what
it feels like to grow up as a
native American drink in
the United States and to feel
unseen,
unvalued, or seen through a
caricature lens. So there are --
and then it's a book that's also
got some really beautiful love
poems and poems that kind of
play with literary history in
beautiful, moving ways.
But this is a poem that is kind
of haunting.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah. Can we
have that now?
>> TRACY SMITH: My
>> My Brother at 3:00 A.M.
He sat cross-legged, weeping on
the steps when mom unlocked and
opened the front door. Oh, God,
he said. He wants to kill me,
Mom. When Mom unlocked and
opened the front door at 3:00
a.m.
, she was in her nightgown. Dad
was  asleep.
He wants to kill me, he told
her, looking over his shoulder.
3:00 a.m.
and in her nightgown, Dad
asleep.
What's going on, she asked. Who
wants to kill you? He looked
over his shoulder. The devil
does. Look at him. Over there.
She asked, what are you on?
Who wants to kill you?
The sky wasn't black or blue,
but the green of a dying night.
The devil, look at him, over
there. He pointed to the corner
house.
The sky wasn't black or blue,
but the dying green of night.
Stars had closed their eyes or
sheathed their knives. My
brother pointed to the corner
house.
His lips flickered with sores,
stars
had closed their eyes or
sheathed their knives. Oh, God,
I can see the tail, he said. Oh,
God, look.
Mom winced at the sores on his
lips. It's sticking out from
behind the
house, oh, God, see the tail, he
said.
Look at the god damned tail. He
sat cross-legged weeping on the
front steps.
Mom finally sighed, a hellish
vision, my brother. Oh, God, oh,
God, she said.
>> RON CHARLES: It doesn't
seem like a political poem at
all, except that it
forces us to do what you hope
poetry will make us do.
>> TRACY SMITH: Mmhmm.
>> RON CHARLES: Which is to
cross over barriers, to
sympathize, to feel
in ways we didn't, with people
we didn't think we knew.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah.
It's a poem that kind of urges
you to say -- to stop saying
that's not my problem and to
say, I wonder what that woman --
>> RON CHARLES: Mother.
>> TRACY SMITH: Feels like.
Or this kid who's watching all
of this. This is one of the
poems that -- this is the last
poem, I think, that we read in
the men's rehab center. I didn't
want to lead with it for obvious
reasons. But I didn't want to
not read it because I wanted to
know what they might make of it.
>> RON CHARLES: Right.
>> TRACY SMITH: And they saw a
lot of
the struggle, this awful monster
that's riding the brother. That
made sense to them.
His inability to really be able
to translate his experience to
the family members, which I
think the poem manages
interestingly by making that
creature
real to the brother, and
invisible to everybody else.
But they also -- I think I'm not
wrong
in  connecting this to that
afternoon. Someone there said
it's interesting, where is the
dad? This is the mom, she's
bearing all the weight.
Suddenly, it's even an
opportunity for someone to
empathize with another figure,
which seems really insightful to
me.
>> RON CHARLES: Right. That
opportunity -- there's a great
poem, gives us to emphasize with
people we don't run into. It's a
great gift.
>> TRACY SMITH: Yeah. I think
it's a great gift.
And I don't think it's one to be
taken lightly. I don't think
it's enough to say yeah,
empathy, kumbaya.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: I think
that's one of the things that
creates a sense of
toxicity that we are all kind
of, you know, reeling from.
We're producing it by writing
off these
simple but potentially
meaningful acts. And so I think,
you know, okay, read a poem and
try and believe in what it
causes you to feel.
>> RON CHARLES: Right.
>> TRACY SMITH: I think that's
actual work.
>> RON CHARLES: Me, too.
You told the New York New York
Times -- that's another
newspaper on the East Coast --
(Laughter)
>> RON CHARLES: There's a Deep a
deep and interesting troubling
that poems do.
>> TRACY SMITH: You know I
like that
word, it's kind of the anchor
for the title poem, which comes
from the song
and the biblical story of an
angel troubling the water so
that it would protect the
Israelites as they were passing
to safety. It would also heal
them of any kind of affliction.
And so troubling is a stirring
up, but, of course, stirring up
is also trouble.
>> RON CHARLES: Yeah.
>> TRACY SMITH: And I think art
is something that asks us to do
both.
>> RON CHARLES: Would you
read a poem
called The United States
Welcomes You, 41?
>> TRACY SMITH: I want to tell
you this poem is another poem
that got a different title after
it was written.
I was thinking about this --
it's pretty close on the wake of
the Civil War poem. I was
thinking about what it feels
like to be taken as a stranger
in the country you belong to.
And then this title was the
title that I wanted to give to
the poem.
The United States Welcomes  You.
Why, and by whose power were you
sent?
What do you see that you may
wish to steal? Why this dancing?
Why do your dark bodies drink up
all the light?
What are you demanding that we
feel? Have you stolen something?
Then what is that leaping in
your chest?
What is the nature of your
mission?
Do you seek to offer a
confession? Have you anything to
do with others brought by us to
harm? Then why are you afraid?
And why do you invade our night,
hands
raised, eyes wide, mute as
ghosts?
Is there something you wish to
confess?
Is this some enigmatic type of
test? What if we fail?
How and to whom do we address
our appeal?
>> RON CHARLES: For an immigrant
nation, this is a really
troubling poem.
You once said you wish that more
poets were  brave, or generous
enough to risk
failing at something that
matters.
What matters most to you as a
poet?
>> TRACY SMITH: I asked a
student that once when she was
in my office. And we were
talking about her poems. And I
was giving her feedback. She
bristled at every suggestion I
made. I said what's going on
here? What's at stake for you?
What's in this room with us
right now that's causing this?
And she said I just want to
write truth. And she burst into
tears.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: And I love her,
you know.
(Laughter)
>> TRACY SMITH: And I feel
that way, too.
I want something that's not just
a testament to me and feeling,
you know,
proud of this momentary thing I
might be or something I feel
like I might know. I want to
write poems that are going to
push me to kind of touch that
big thing, you know. And you
mostly won't, right. That's the
failure that I'm kind of setting
myself up for. But the wish is,
like, I want something
that's going to make this life
kind of bearable, you know? Or
something.
I mean, the less, kind of,
like, lofty answer is I'm
interested in what
we do to each other in all the
contexts that we operate in --
in families, in
relationships, in society, and
what's the fallout from that and
what could we take from that.
>> RON CHARLES: It's such an
honor to talk to you and hear
you talk about poetry. Thank you
so much.
>> TRACY SMITH: My honor.
Thank you.
(Applause)
>> Thank you, Tracy and Ron. I
have just a few announcements
before I let you all go. First
of all, a week from today the
center will kick off its
first-ever
podcast series, featuring our
21st Poet Laureate. I know it's
technology, but it's still worth
listening to.
(Laughter)
>> This is the website.
>> Give into your inner techy
self and go there, please.
Second, if you haven't already,
please fill out the survey forms
when you received when coming
in.
You can drop them off at the
table in the foyer. Your input
helps us improve events such as
these.
And we'll have a book signing in
the pavilion next door.
We hope you'll get a signed copy
and congratulate Tracy. Finally,
this event concludes the
literary season, but I would be
remiss if I didn't tell you that
down the
street is a big poetry festival
taking place.
Splitthis
This Rock has free evening
readings.
You can go to the website, look
around, keep your ears open,
hear some poetry, it will be
great. Enjoy the rest of
National Poetry
Month, and hope to see you back
here soon. Thank you.
(Applause)